podemos dividir la respuesta rusa en dos
también se especula con que el banco
putina seguido en los últimos años
contraofensiva económica del kremlin
cierto modo el plan greg fue todo un
derecha de putin en la economía rusa
pocas semanas tras la invasión rusia se
ejemplo se limitaron los retiros de las
amigos amigas en 2014 el gobierno ruso
haciendo y qué pretende hacer atentos la
el desarrollo ahora bien retomemos las
si tienes una moneda tan intervenida
comunidad visual político este es el
que los rusos van a pagar muy caro la
según el propio banco central de rusia
puede resultar más fácil de decir que de
de marzo del gobierno suprimió el
el petróleo y el gas están por las nubes
puso en marcha su agenda más
mucha más autoridad de la que tienen la
central de rusia ha podido acumular en
también se está planteando que luego
con rublos hoy por hoy puede no resultar
terminaron muy pronto entre los años
círculos liberales de rusia ha sido una
rusia en el pib mundial la situación 20
colapso económico estos son los dos
un nuevo zar para un imperio en
partes las medidas de corto plazo y la
éxito si la corrupción siguió por las
hemos podido ver el enorme impacto que
cuentas bancarias en divisa extranjera
preguntas que nos hacíamos al principio
impuesto sobre la compra de metales
plan de putin aislarse de las economías
tampoco tiene mucho mérito y desde luego
nacionalista y despótica y todo apunta a
convirtió en una especie de país paria y
invasión de ucrania no solo está siendo
mayoría de sus homólogos internacionales
comenzó a desarrollar un plan de
hacer hoy por hoy no parece nada fácil
tan sencillo ni tampoco deseable para
algunas de estas empresas puedan cotizar
el pib de este país se desplomara al
sus propias bóvedas unos 30.000 millones
como espera a vladimir putin hacer
agresión contra ucrania sobre todo si
2002 y 2008 los precios del petróleo se
objetivos que se ha fijado el gobierno
preciosos digamos que si los rusos
llamados récords de 14 años por culpa
se estableció un impuesto e incluso para
como espera vladimir putin hacer frente
años después de hacerse con el poder
nubes pero las cosas en rúsia mejoraron
occidentales fortalecer su divisa con el
de las manos derechas de putin desde que
decadencia
porque en a violín a lo controla todo
no impide el resto de efectos sobre la
estrategia para hacer que la economía
una enorme pesadilla en el campo de
tiene la corrupción en la desastrosa
en mercados offshore donde puedan
que el plan de putin pueda tener éxito
ruso como una prioridad absoluta pues
contingencia que ahora tiene que
aislado con gran parte del espacio aéreo
menos un 8% en 2022 una previsión que el
los gobiernos y las grandes
los países europeos y el resto de
frente a las sanciones internacionales
querían proteger sus ahorros y no se
había regresado al punto de partida si
de dólares en efectivo contante y
mucho el gobierno ruso impulsó la
rusa resista durante los próximos meses
oro recuperar los activos nacionales y
las finanzas la política monetaria los
multinacionales la idea es que éstos
multiplicaron prácticamente por 4 esto
éste se hizo con los mandos del país
recaudar dinero de inversores de países
economía local por ejemplo dejar de
actuación del ejército ruso en ucrania
algunos casos la prohibición temporal a
batalla también está teniendo un impacto
gran medida de la falta de inversión y
a las sanciones internacionales qué plan
mundial cerrado a cal y canto para sus
fiaban del rublo que compraran oro en el
aplicarse por completo un plan en el que
bien elvira nabiúlina la gobernadora del
aliados comienzan a reducir las compras
os lo hemos contado en varios vídeos
rusia está cada vez más aislada de la
privatización y la desregulación de
e incluso años si tal y como parece el
confiar en que china la india y otros
los rusos son hoy más ricos que en el
sonante y el caso es que todo esto le
menos hostiles de países como china o
primero fue viceministra de desarrollo
terminen pagando sus compras en oro el
seguros los fondos de inversión la banca
importar componentes reduce si la
ganar la guerra económica con qué
sea como sea el caso es que ahora con
bajo semejante contexto la invasión rusa
la compra de moneda extranjera y se
tiene pues bien lo primero de todo es
económico mucho mayor del esperado y
hizo que el gobierno ruso pasara ya de
mercado local en lugar de dólares libras
banco europeo para la reconstrucción y
banco central de rusia es uno de los
juega un papel clave esta mujer que veis
aviones con las empresas internacionales
año 2000 pero no ha mejorado más de lo
aquí en visual político la caída de la
amplios sectores de la economía se buscó
podría dar cierto oxígeno al gobierno de
castigo se prolonga en el tiempo en esta
de petróleo y gas ruso si eso se produce
de las reservas del gobierno en el
países similares puedan funcionar como
las petromonarquías del golfo pérsico
economía mundial y tal y como ya vimos
activos cuenta exactamente rusia para
demanda de dólares pero puede suponer
cual se intercambiaría en rublos al
económico y comercio en 2007 fue
obligó a las empresas exportadoras a
actores clave para conseguir el segundo
saber exactamente cómo se encuentra
las sanciones aprobadas contra este país
o euros pues bien según sberbank la
terreno financiero es probablemente la
huyendo despavorida excluidos en gran
de ucrania ha sido algo así como el
putin para seguir operando en el mercado
unión soviética y la transición a una
particularmente en el caso de la
atraer a los inversores internacionales
en pantalla elvira nabiúlina sí vale lo
el desarrollo eleva hasta el 10 por
línea desde el 2014 lo primero que hizo
precio fijado por el banco central a ver
que muchas empresas locales se terminen
un salvavidas suficiente como para
haciendo que estos inversores pues no
aquí en visual político es posible que
disputar esta batalla porque el rublo se
objetivo nabiúlina que procede de los
y tenemos en cuenta lo dependiente que
ascendida administra de este mismo campo
persona más importante de toda la rusia
internacional por ejemplo podrían auto
tras la invasión de ucrania las cosas
actualmente rusia y que ha caracterizado
que es mucho peor la economía rusa cada
repatriar y convertir a rublos el 80 por
demanda de oro se cuadriplicó durante
fenómeno fue exactamente el contrario
economía rusa nadie moscú imaginaba que
capear esta tormenta claro que esto
y se estableció un impuesto fijo sobre
no se trataba a pesar de lo que están
viniendo abajo pensadas que el rubro de
corran el riesgo de sus acciones
remate por eso ha comenzado a extenderse
economía de mercado fue de todo menos un
ciento el banco mundial por encima del
el gobierno ruso fue incrementar sus
medida del sistema financiero
sé es la típica imagen de un oligarca
desplomó tras la invasión pero luego al
ni siquiera china venga a su rescate
comprarse la deuda externa de rusia por
poco a poco la economía rusa fue
es la economía rusa de ventas
diciendo muchos medios de comunicación
prometen ponerse mucho pero que mucho
y también la gente rusa con mayor
las primeras semanas de marzo el
hasta el 2012 luego ejerció como la
la etapa de putin al frente del timón
la renta del 13% un flat tax que hizo
vez está más dominada por grandes
la unión soviética- que no valía
una pregunta podría el hidrógeno llegar
con cara de malo pero esta mujer
reservas extranjeras e incrementar el
11 por ciento y el instituto de finanzas
de volver al patrón oro ni nada por el
poco tiempo recuperó prácticamente todo
camino de rosas la mala gestión
energéticas entonces el colapso sería
internacional y cargando con un montón
ciento de sus ingresos en el extranjero
objetivo amigos de todas estas medidas
las cosas en 2022 fueron a ir tan mal lo
solo sentiremos el impacto real cuando
prestigio internacional durante años su
una fracción de su valor o pagar
prácticamente para nada tenía un tipo de
pivotando más y más en torno al kremlin
empresas ineficientes y corruptas cuya
atentos pero un momento antes de
peor y como veis no parece que a rusia
asesora principal del presidente para
económica la corrupción galopante las
peso de activos como el yuan o el oro y
encabeza la contraofensiva con la que
a sustituir al gas ruso que empresas y
era frenar a toda costa la huida de
también se prohibió a los inversores
estilo porque la moneda rusa no será
que putin ganaran muchos puntos en la
por último el kremlin ya ha anunciado
su valor quiere decir a caso de esto que
internacionales hasta el 15 por ciento
importaciones o inversiones críticas
objetivo fue estabilizar el rublo y
de restricciones comerciales tan sólo en
cambio oficial de 0.6 rublos por dólar
las líneas de producción se rompan la
con mucha diferencia el escenario más
asuntos económicos y desde el 2013 ocupa
llegue a esta crucial batalla en su
posiblemente esconder una buena parte de
al tiempo que la corrupción seguía por
comunidad económica internacional el
luego por otra parte nada más aprobarse
convertible en ningún caso pero digamos
actividad depende fundamentalmente del
el kremlin se está saliendo con la suya
capitales y con ello el hundimiento del
combatir la inflación algo que hizo con
continuar los precios de la electricidad
extranjeros liquidar sus posiciones en
que se anunció como una operación
finanzas públicas casi quebradas y por
putin quiere ganar o al menos resistir
hablamos en cualquier caso de la peor
moscú son decenas y decenas de miles de
de la misma forma que el peso argentino
que reforzará la política de sustitución
países están liderando esta nueva
queridos amigos amigas en este vídeo
mayor parte de lo que se produce en
caso es que estas reformas junto con los
que es una forma de fortalecer el rublo
las nubes y los sucesivos planes de
probable digámoslo alto y claro no hay
rublo algo que temporalmente la señora
especial se ha terminado convirtiendo en
las sanciones internacionales y el banco
ellas y si lo habéis escuchado bien se
favor del gobierno esto es lo que
el cargo de gobernadora del banco
mejor momento la economía rusa está
mano de hierro llegó a cerrar 500 bancos
la bolsa de moscú o recibir el pago de
último una gigantesca crisis financiera
la guerra económica que los aliados han
también tiene un tipo de cambio oficial
recesión en rusia desde principios de la
revolución energética no te pierdas el
rusia depende de componentes fabricados
vamos a responder a todas estas
incrementar las reservas de oro rusas y
nabiúlina consiguió aunque eso sí el
de importaciones apoyando con
crecientes precios del crudo dispararon
sospecha que el banco central de rusia
central ruso respondió con un paquete de
puestos de trabajo los que ahora están
reformas que se presentaban nunca
explica por ejemplo que rusia
repleta de corrupción más allá de las
plan que pueda soportar un impacto
central algo que por cierto hace con
y luego otro tipo de mercado que es muy
una intensa y pesada guerra con un
en occidente y así sin estas piezas el
elevó los tipos de interés muy por
preguntas así que arranquemos la guerra
dividendos o intereses incluso el día 9
ha podido esconder lejos del alcance de
vídeo que han hecho en si lo hubiera
lanzado contra rusia atentos la mano
financiación barata a las empresas
básicamente sólo exporte materias primas
muy importante atacar el sistema de los
hicieron de los años 90 una década
emergencia que incluye una subida de
el ingreso per cápita ruso desde los
década de 1990 y ojo porque hablamos tan
precio fuera hacer del rublo una moneda
en peligro por la salida de las empresas
pero que muy distinto sea como sea estas
llegaban a ponerse en marcha esto junto
encima de los cánones internacionales y
semejante pero llegas hasta aquí turno
sabido el canal de información
materias primas sus empresas son muy
gigantesco coste en términos de vidas
las sanciones internacionales decenas de
tipos hasta el 20 por ciento más tarde
trabajo se detendrá en las fábricas de
nacionales al tiempo que confía que
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
son las medidas urgentes pensadas para
intervenida y prácticamente inútil en el
petrodólares esto es la compra de
2000 dólares hasta un máximo de 16 mil a
dramática para rusia por ejemplo entre
multinacionales y no lo decimos nosotros
ineficientes y tanto el consumo como la
liberalizó el rublo para promover la
al hundimiento de los precios del
miles de millones de dólares en cuentas
para ti crees que la economía rusa
fijados en el 17 y la imposición de
automóviles en la perforación en altamar
países como china e india pueden
solo del primer año a medio y largo
el corto plazo pero la pregunta es que
equipos y recursos de todo tipo una
integración de rusia la economía
panorama internacional en cualquier caso
participamos os dejamos el enlace abajo
petróleo 2014 y con sanciones tras la
petróleo utilizando la divisa del 'tío
lo dice el propio alcalde de la capital
1990 y 1998 el pib per cápita real de
propia producción local dependen en gran
offshore opacas se habla de hasta 80 mil
conseguirá sortear las sanciones
internacional claro que también acabó
comienzos de la década del 2010 un
en la aviación etcétera natalia psuv
fuertes controles de capitales por
dos en estos controles de capital junto
plazo son muchos los analistas que
sam' algo que se considera como uno de
espera hacer rusia si esta situación se
terminar siendo todo un salvavidas para
guerra que también ha desatado una
en la descripción y ahora sí continuemos
alentando la nacionalización de casi el
internacionales puede la guerra
millones de dólares en títulos de deuda
despegue que por supuesto multiplicó la
invasión de crimea hicieron que las
al desplome de las importaciones lo que
prolonga durante años pues amigos lo
los cimientos del valor del dólar y que
rusa fijaos según nuestras estimaciones
medida de suministros internacionales
arevich economista y geógrafo rusa
apuntan a que las cosas se pondrán aún
su economía incluso espera que las
del gobierno de los eeuu escondidos a
reacción internacional de tal calibre
70 por ciento del sistema bancario ruso
los rusos se desplomó más de un 40 por
económica desatada por occidente llegar
explica que el rublo se disparará
cosas seguirán la vuelta fijaos en este
países como china ya están intentando
primero ha sido anunciar que en el
hasta ahora quizás lo mejor que ha hecho
popularidad de putin dentro y fuera de
unas 200.000 personas corren el riesgo
tampoco podemos decir que nos sorprendan
sanciones no vayan mucho más allá o se
peor mucho peor las mejores estimaciones
durante el mes de marzo hasta recuperar
futuro se exigirá que el pago de sus
que ha superado cualquier plan de
emocionar el problema de todo esto es
pero eso es otra historia el caso es que
a tumbar al régimen de putin durarán las
gráfico si miramos la participación de
través de empresas superpuestas en
rusia el problema es que la reforma se
ciento y eso que el punto de partida no
putin ha sido mantener a raya el gasto y
los planes de putin en materia económica
su valor previo a la invasión claro que
exportaciones de materias primas se haga
de perder sus puestos de trabajo sérguei
den pronto la vuelta aunque sea
ahora sus metas han cambiado por
lugares como las islas caimán o incluso
que al final rusia puede terminar
contingencia manejado por el kremlin en
que estoy viendo salir ahora mismo
era precisamente para echar cohetes pues
llevan mucho tiempo sin funcionar en los
sanciones el tiempo suficiente deben los
completo durante años el banco central
parcialmente en moscú entienden que el
vendiendo muchas menos materias primas y
en rublos al mismo tiempo que el banco
la deuda pública sobre todo tras la
sobiánin alcalde de moscú tras desatarse
bélgica donde tiene su sede euro crear
sugieren que la economía rusa va a
bien de semejante debacle surgió
últimos años la economía rusa ha ido de
también teniendo muchas menos divisas
central ha establecido un precio fijo
países aliados incrementar su castigo
mundo no estará dispuesto a prescindir
hizo todo lo posible para ayudar a rusia
la tormenta de fuego en ucrania el
recortarse a la mitad de lo que era
una de las compañías de custodia de
vladimir putin se convirtió en
extranjeras con las que operar en el
mal en peor desde su máximo de 16 mil
entendió tras recibir las primeras
para las compras de oro cinco mil rublos
de sus materias primas pues bien querida
panorama para la economía rusa se ha
a integrarse aún más en la economía
activos más importantes del planeta
antes de esta invasión del ipp singh
presidente en el año 2000 prometiendo
mercado internacional pero bien luego
hacia rusia déjanos por aquí abajo tus
sanciones que tener unas cuentas
por gramo de oro y la pregunta es todo
vuelto tenebroso a medida que las
asesor adjunto de seguridad nacional de
por otro lado el gobierno ruso parece
mundial entonces de repente el 24 de
comentarios ya sabes si este vídeo te ha
poner en marcha un amplio proceso de
dólares el ingreso per cápita ruso había
públicas saneadas y muchas reservas
estar preparando una estrategia para
los eeuu habrá menos inversión menos
esto para qué pues veréis como hacerse
sanciones han ahogado las importaciones
resultado interesante no olvides darle
reformas para modernizar el país
febrero tuvo que hacer todo lo contrario
comprar las acciones rusas y los activos
caído hasta el entorno de los 12.000
internacionales era algo necesario para
que muchas empresas rusas están teniendo
al botón de like y por supuesto
empezando por supuesto por la economía y
comercio internacional menos integración
en manos de los inversores extranjeros
andrei moves and ex ejecutivo de banco
antes de la invasión de ucrania y ahora
suscribirte a visual política una vez
que reducir sus operaciones por falta de
disputar la guerra económica y es que
por supuesto con un fuerte descuento la
ruso y actualmente financiero en londres
eso fue exactamente lo que hizo al poco
de rusia en las cadenas de valor
con las sanciones todo apunta a que
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
suministros que cientos de empresas
mundiales y esto combinado con la gente
amigos putin la acaba de renovar para un
idea sería algo así como crear un grupo
de llegar al poder el gobierno de putin
caerá muy por debajo de los diez mil
occidentales están abandonando el país y
saludo y hasta la próxima
de campeones nacionales grandes empresas
puso en marcha el llamado plan craft un
tercer mandato y ya es ahora la
que abandona rusia significa un menor
dólares esto supondría una contracción
que miles de rusos están perdiendo sus
encargada de liderar la respuesta
que se hicieran prácticamente con todo
crecimiento de la productividad a largo
económica de rusia la pregunta es qué ha
plan que buscaba atraer inversores en
vamos potenciar aún más lo que ha sido
puestos de trabajo la economía rusa se
de casi el 50 por ciento desde que el
plazo beata llavorsí economista jefe del
hecho para preparar a este qué está
la estrategia de control económico de
está tan para que os hagáis una idea
gobierno ruso a un lado las reformas y
banco europeo para la reconstrucción y
[Música]